this is another thing this is ethical
thing okay doesn't it we can't take kids
away from their parents but there's an
example i love i don't i don't know if
you've heard it but there's a
girl called oxana malaya who was born in
the ukraine
in a really run-down village and her
parents were alcoholics
and one night they left her out in the
cold they just left her outside and
looking for warmth she curled up with
feral dogs
she was three years old at this time and
she lived with the dogs for the next
five years until someone reported it to
the authorities but she couldn't talk
she walked on all fours she drank like a
dog she barked
and i mean she's one example and you
know with science you'll say you need
thousands of examples to be able to say
this is actually what's happening
but to me it's such a clear example
of what happens if you don't have people
around you you don't know how to talk
because no one's talking to you you
don't know how to drink or eat
or walk
i'm joined by fiona merden fiona welcome
to the show hi
thanks great to be here pleasure to have
you on what is the mirror system
the mirror system is a collection of
neurons in the brain which enable us to
observe what other people are doing
without actually carrying out that
action ourselves
and how that functions is to enable us
to learn
basically because for thousands and
thousands of years before we had the
written word
the only way we could learn was through
observing and actually through
storytelling as well which
interestingly is also dependent in part
on the neuro
the mirror neuron that's interesting
so how does it work how do i i watch you
doing a thing you're
whittling a stick or i don't know what
our ancestors would be doing
hunting a deer how does it work so
it's easiest to go back to where how it
was discovered because it was discovered
in palmer
by um uh
some italian psychophysiologists or
i've got the name wrong there but they
were basic they were looking at
how monkeys grasp and they had
electrodes in this is bit mean into the
brains of the monkeys
and one day they were eating their lunch
and they noticed that the monkeys were
doing the grasping on in terms of what
electrical output was coming off
but they weren't actually moving and so
they realized that the same
part of the brain was functioning when
the monkeys were watching
as when the monkeys were actually doing
it themselves
and so if you think about it if you
think about a baby for example
watching a mother or a mum or dad eating
they might be watching them when they're
not eating themselves but each time
they're watching they're rehearsing it
through in their brain which helps
to build up that capability of how to
actually do that
ourselves and this is just automated
yeah i mean it's complex it's so some
people actually
argue against the marijuana but that's
going down a really geeky path
we love we love we love a geeky path oh
no it's very very geeky
um from there's there's still
within the brain of humans we can't
generally do single neuron analysis so
that analysis that was being carried out
on monkeys was a single neuron
um within the brain of humans we use
something called fmri which is
functional magnetic resolution imaging
and it gives us
an idea of what's going on the brain
through blood flow
that can't help us get down to that
individual level and there have been
some
um experiments where people have been
having surgery for epilepsy and they've
given consent for their brains to be
looked at
but what some scientists will say we
haven't gathered enough
data to be able to say this is
definitely how it happens or this isn't
how it happens
is it just because in order to be able
to do that single neuron
analysis you got a trapan part of the
brain or whatever and then get a neuron
is that that's
literally an ethical question yeah oh
interesting
i thought it might have been due to like
density or complexity or the number of
neurons that we have or something like
that
so i'm not a neuroscientist i would
probably put it
to both points but i think the major
point
is that we can't go around people's
heads
if you want if you want to have a hole
drilled in your head comment below
and fiona will put you in touch with
someone who wants to drill a hole in
your head yeah i know lots of people who
would want to do it i just
whether or not the board didn't exactly
so the advantage that the mirror neuron
gave our ancestors was expediting
learning was that it
yeah i mean it was it was how
civilization progressed where it is
today
so before a written word it was the only
way there was a progression of
of learning so one one guy
calls it uh collective learning
he talks about big history and
collective learning so every generation
builds on the learning from the
generation before and it gradually
evolves how we learn and what we know
but before we could write things down
that was the only way that we could
evolve from
sort of just sitting with our stick
whittling to actually
building a hut or or sort of creating
fire or all that sort of stuff
i guess it's more scalable and less open
to
linguistic restrictions and or
interpretation of someone trying to
vocalize the thing that they're doing
like if i can hunt a deer you can watch
me hunt a deer and take
the cues of me hunting a deer but i
might not actually be able to explain
what it is that i do we might not have
sufficiently sophisticated language you
might not be able to
hear the same that i speak that blah
blah blah
exactly and it's so the example i give
is
if you um look at how someone throws the
ball up to serve in tennis
so if i was to explain that i thought in
the in the book i've basically
taken it down to various different steps
you read that through if you've never
played tennis and you've never seen
anyone
serve you would think what on earth am i
supposed to do
because it's just it looks impossible
and it kind of makes you realize that
even now we have to see things to be
able to
do them because that's the way our
brains evolved yes instruction helps of
course it does
but we still fundamentally rely on that
being able to see
that's so interesting because if you
were to think about any
complex physical movement dancing
martial arts
um you never even if you pay for a
course online
it's never an instructor in front of you
simply saying what you do
he's demonstrating along with it right
so the vocalizing the linguistics
wrap additional information around
perhaps the feel of the muscles that
you're activating so it's the stuff that
you can't see
but the vast majority of the cues are
coming from things that you can see
absolutely yeah i remember in atomic
habits by james cleary says that we've
got
14 million sense sensing
um cells in our body
and 11 million of them at a site
dedicated to site and only three million
to the remaining four senses
it's really interesting but actually on
that point
mirror neurons are thought to be
associated with auditory
as well as visual um that's interesting
and and um there's so
i mean a good example of it is actually
when you come to storytelling so if you
if you tell their experiments have been
done where you've got someone
tasting a certain taste and you describe
the taste so this is linguistics
and you explain how um something
sounds something smells and it's if you
think about
uh martin luther king so on the i'll get
it wrong the quote
you know if you think about the red
hills of georgia
in the sweltering heat and apologies to
any martin luther king
i am a fan but i'm not very good at
remembering things it's
it brings those metaphors enable us to
create the image in our own head and
when
when um neuroscientists look at people
listening to a story it will activate
the same areas of their
brain as what is being described in that
story
that's cool does it start imprinting
from birth we started printing before
birth can we imprint when we're still in
the womb
i mean there's that that's another geeky
one because
i'm just so you remember you said about
tennis i'm just throwing up a bunch of
balls
that you want to you want to hit because
you want to go down the rabbit hole
i'm missing them um there's something
called epigenetics which is
where our genes are actually turned on
and off themselves by the chemicals
um that they're sort of soaked in
so epigenetics will influence that
there's
some so there's a lady called celia
hayes who's at oxford university and she
believes that the mirror neuron
begins developing once we're born but
very very quickly
so it's sort of it it potentially might
have formed in some sort of way before
we're born but it's when we're born that
it starts
developing not imprinted before that
yeah
so is there a period i don't know
whether this is possible again with the
uh ethical questions that we've got
around brain imaging
is there a period in which the most
imprinting is done
i don't know the exact answer to that
but obviously kids are very susceptible
to stuff
but kids will mirror their parents
predominantly until they're about
12 13 and then it becomes peers teachers
all those sorts of people as well
but still predominantly actually for all
of us it's our parents
but teenagers um their brain
is wired to be social because that's how
again in evolutionary terms that's how
teenagers operated they were going to
reproduce so they had to be social how
to meet people
and so they're very um their brains
quite malleable to what's going on
around them and they need that
information being fed to them but the
brain continues to develop until we're
in our sort of mid to late 20s something
called emerging adulthood
so we used to think it stopped um but it
doesn't
and then even when we're adults it's
still again
something i'm sure you've heard is the
term plastic so our brain we used to
think
especially psychologists that our brain
our personality everything was fixed
once we hit a certain age but we're
learning more and more it's not
you said about parents being the key
determinant there
i'm going to guess that a parent's
accent is a
key uh example that everyone can
understand is that is that mirroring the
fact that if you're irish
and your parents sound irish you've got
a bit of an irish twang
i mean it's a cultural it's a cultural
norm so
you're picking up the values but you're
also picking out what's around you and i
find that really interesting because
um my daughter's got a friend
who we live in southeast of england
and she's got a friend whose mum's from
manchester and
we've known them since she was three so
she's 13
now nearly 14. and she speaks with a a
mancunian accent
no way yeah and so and so that's clearly
the influence of her mum it's not her
mum saying you need to talk like me
but there'll be that influence there
she's picking it up
from her mum rather than the people that
are around her in her environment
well that's surely that is a controlled
variable here is where it's imprinting
from like
unless there's someone that's from
manchester sneaking into a bedroom at
night and whispering
whispering it's a mum it's a mum surely
at night all right like me you will talk
that would be funny or just liam
gallagher's rogue at night
whispering in his small children's ears
so what happens if i grew up with
sheep if i was born and left and i
went down the stream in a wood wicker
basket like some
biblical myth and i wake up and i'm
surrounded by sheep
this is another thing this is ethical
thing okay doesn't it we can't take kids
away from the parents
but there's an example i love i don't i
don't know if you've heard it but
there's a girl called oksana malaya
who um was born in the ukraine
in a really run-down village and her
parents were alcoholics
and one night they left her out in the
cold they just
left her outside this is how the story
goes and looking for warmth she curled
up with feral dogs
and she she was three years old at this
time and she lived with the dogs for the
next five years until someone reported
it to the authorities
but she couldn't talk she walked on all
fours
she drank like a dog um
she barked so when i say drank life dog
there's video of her and she sort of
licks as the tap
drips you know she's looking and
i mean she's one example and you know
with science you'll say you need
you need thousands of examples to be
able to say this is actually what's
happening
but to me it's such a clear example
of what happens if you don't have people
around you
you don't know how to talk because no
one's talking to you
you don't know how to drink or eat or
walk
so although we're sort of like you know
you might say well why didn't she learn
to walk up right anyway
because everything everyone around her
was walking on all fours
that example's so mind-blowing
it's it's one of these things this is
why i can't wait well if we're living in
a simulation it doesn't matter there's
no ethics anyway
but this is why i can't wait until we
can properly properly do simulations of
consciousness
because all these questions will just be
answered right okay let's create a
universe
in which you live with sheep or you live
with this or you live with that and
oh my god look at that bleeding and
trying to grow wool
and and jumping jumping over fences when
people can't get to sleep and
everything um so can we choose not
to imitate other people when we're young
do we have enough agency below the age
of whatever 13 can i
choose to not be like my parents or is
it kind of
is there a glass bottom to that again i
don't know the hard answer these are
good
quest answers on good questions drilling
away this evening trying to find the
real points that we're here for
so um
what what is what's called counter
mirroring and if you think about
it in you you think about it in your own
life there'll be times where you've seen
someone doing something and you can
imagine this in a playground so you can
imagine a kid in the playground smacking
another kid around the head
and and you look at it and you think do
you know what
i know that he got that football back
from that guy
but he got in a whole load of trouble
from
the teachers about that and and that
there's a decision point because it's
conscious
as soon as it becomes conscious it's
something you can make a decision on
and there must be i mean there must be
times where we unconsciously make a
decision on not
imitating but a lot of the time to make
it
to not imitate we have to stop and
actually pause and think
hang on a minute do i really want to
behave like that or do i want to behave
like that
and you find that in business because i
profile a lot of senior executives
and i go through their life from um sort
of teenage years up to where they're at
and it'll be i had this awful boss
and i decided there and then i was never
going to lead like that
and that's a prime example of counter
mirroring is saying i had that boss i
didn't like what i saw
and so i decided i'm never going to do
that i'm going to guess as well
there'll be a lot of people who might
have the um
the father who drank a bit much
so decides that they're going to control
their drinking but perhaps only after
beginning to move down that path as a
young adult
and then almost using latent mirroring
or latent
counter mirroring as like here is
something i did see in the past
this is something that i know that i
should avoid in the future
yeah and i know people like that
actually who had alcoholic parents and
who've
made that decision i don't want to be
like that they've they maybe slipped
they've started sipping and and realized
actually well
um you know joey over there he can drink
10 pints and he just has an awful
hangover when i do it i want to again
and again and again um so
there's that recognition whereas joey
might end up an alcoholic
have you read robert plowman's blueprint
no oh i need to get you on this if you
are if you have space
in the reading list put it on my list
so he is a i'm going to get this wrong
behavioral geneticist
oh cool um and basically he's the
leading twin studies adoption studies
guy on the planet and his most recent
book blueprint
is phenomenal and basically the synopsis
the golden rule of behavioral genetics
is that everything every psychological
trait that we have
has a significant genetic
uh factor contributing to it and that
fifty percent of
everything you are is because of your
parents
fifty percent of everything across the
board and one of the main things that he
looked at one of the key things
uh uh key areas that he looked at was
alcoholism and addiction
and alcoholism and addiction correlates
it's in it's like 0.8 or like
0.7 it is insane
so what i've been i'm a big fan of a
meritocracy
right as a lot of i guess young sort of
entrepreneurial type people like i'll
you know make it on my own all this
stuff um
and upon finding out about just how
uh sort of deterministic our genes are
and then reading mirror thinking your
book
and realizing that a lot of the stuff
that we do has been imprinted on us
it's almost like a like a one-two from
our parents and the environment that we
grow up in right
you're given this particular nature
that is then probably backed up in part
by the nurture
yeah absolutely absolutely and that's
where
i think it's so powerful because you
know on one hand people say oh you know
we're role modeling or observing it's
really obvious
um anything it is obvious but that
doesn't mean
that we take conscious control of it or
that we use it to help
society so my bug bear
my book bear is that um commercial
organizations
use an understanding of our sort of
limbic system basically
to hook us onto social media have you
watched i'm going to guess you'll have
seen the most recent tristan harris
documentary
oh yeah i had a few issues with some of
that but yeah just because
just from this though just from things
like when they talked about
psychometrics and i'm like that's not
psychometrics and
but it must be a curse to have
expertise in a particular area watching
it oh wow
so i think i think he's brilliant i love
him and i follow him and i love that
he's got such an extreme view
um but when i was actually watching this
i was thinking i can't believe that a
psychiatrist from stamford
is saying this and that's what she said
was completely correct
but then it was taken out of context
within the world is that susanna's
which one remember her surname is one
with a huge net with huge hair
don't think so no she had her two kids
on it
i had to stop watching it because i was
getting too annoyed i do remember the
person who had her two kids on it it
wasn't the lady that i was thinking
about
um but yeah i always think about that
doctor and when you have specialist
knowledge you're just cursed
with seeing that i can just enjoy it in
ignorance and believe that it's all true
whereas you're just winding me up i was
just going i say all due respect to
these guys
they created some really interesting
technology they did hook people that was
their intention
but they don't have a deep understanding
of psychology and you don't need to have
a deep understanding of psychology but
that's also what's so scary about
it it's like these commercial
organizations are taking over but that's
like the
the most primitive part of our brain and
then the more advanced part of our brain
where we have meaning purpose we give
back to society
that bit needs nurturing empathy
through through mirroring and through
making a conscious decision of what
we're going to absorb and how we're
going to absorb it
and then i also think it's you know
you're saying about
deterministic and you think about these
kids that are born into
really underprivileged environments and
unless we step in and we say because
let's put let's help them let's give
them positive role models
let's enable them to fulfill their
potential
how do they unless they're one
particular person that's gone down a
certain route who's stubborn or whatever
but there's there's a guy i um it's like
getting excited now but there's a guy
that
did a little video clips for me at the
beginning of this um
beginning of launch in the book and he's
called junior smart
and he went to prison for 10 years
and he describes his role models to me
on this video it's only like three
minute video and basically
he said when he was in prison he decided
i'm not going to do this anymore i'm not
going to be involved in gangs and all
that sort of stuff
and then i kind of analyzed it as a
psychologist and of course i don't know
the exact answer but i would hypothesize
if you look at it
because he had a great mum who really
cared about him
he had a great sister who really cared
about him and he had a few people in his
life
so whilst he got pulled into doing so
you know doing crime
gang and being violent he now
he now works with kids to stop them
getting involved in the same thing
that's really cool i had a chris dau qc
queen's council lawyer one of the best
known
criminal law advocates in the uk i had
him on him for his
most recent book justice on trial
uh and he's advocating close all prisons
legalized drugs full works
as a qc really and one of his main
reasons for it is the recidivism rate
just that the sheer he calls prisons
universities of crime
yeah and he says that you go in and
you've just surrounded by this so to
have a person
who peels off and is the exception to
that rule is
is really really cool i might get in
contact with him i totally agree because
basically you're mirroring you're
mirroring the environment you're in
unless you make a conscious decision not
to
what are some of the most important
factors that are influenced by our
parents
our values so our values remain
influenced by parents
throughout life unless unless we make a
conscious decision to change them which
we generally don't unless we have some
sort of major life event
so even teenagers whilst they're being
influenced by their peers still look
to their parents in terms of values what
sort of values
so the type of stuff that under
in some communities you'd put under
religion
if you're agnostic atheists or whatever
you would
it's about being good to other people
it's about
whether you give money to charity it's
about having a heart good work ethic
um it's about
how you treat other people how you how
you contribute to society all those
sorts of things
which really again sort of relate to the
advanced thinking brain
when it comes to being human
but stuff like the value of
money and or materialistic desires
um how you show love to other people how
you show appreciation to other people if
you come from a materialistic household
is that the sort of thing that could be
imprinted
i've had a theory for a while that we
all have a materialism set point
um in life everyone knows the person
kind of like the hedonic set point right
um uh everyone knows the friend from
school whose
parents were always keeping up with the
joneses had like real extravagant
birthdays dad always had a new car on
ppc or whatever it is and um
then you know the other people who
perhaps aren't like that
and my argument during all of the
financial conversations that i've had
on the show has been if you know that
you come
from family a keeping up with the
joneses
you better hope that you get a good job
and you better hope that you are earning
a lot of money
because unless you can de-program the
connection between your sense of
self-worth and the amount of
materialistic success that you've got
you are always going to feel kind of a
little bit tarnished
um and i'm yet to see someone for whom
that isn't true
unless and this is something i'm
fascinated by you keep on talking about
it
us stepping into our own programming and
that
for me is the most interesting part of
life
so i'm guessing you've heard of read
victor frankel man's search for meaning
multiple times so if you
yeah so i mean i think everyone quotes
if if you look at victor frankl when he
looked at the the um
when he was in out switch was he
announced which he was in one of the
concentration camps
no thank you um the people that survived
were the people that had the most
meaning
and then there's um a guy called todd
kashdan who's
um a psychologist who american
psychologist he looks at curiosity
and purpose and meaning and well-being
and him and his colleagues have got
loads and loads of research so that
if you have a sense of purpose and
meaning you
are happier as opposed to the
hedonistic type games that you might get
through money
but what i found really interesting is
because i've worked with a lot with
senior leaders
and some of them are in you know they
bucket loads of money and it's never
really
appealed to me but then i look at my
background and it's never been
a high priority for my parents so to
your point
but there's one guy who i absolutely
love who's ceo of a really cool company
and we talk a lot about this sort of
stuff because we sort of get
geeked out and um he talks about
his friends and there's one friend in
particular who was just driven to earn
millions and millions and he did and he
was miserable
you know it's the classic story he then
said well actually now i think i'm gonna
go and work with that charity
and suddenly this guy is so much happier
than he's ever been
and that's because he suddenly he's got
a sense of purpose rather than chasing
something
hedonistic which is a short-term goal
a couple of things firstly roy
baumeister
wrote a wonderful purpose and meaning
article have you read it
yes i mean yeah he's one of my i think
i've referenced him
either in my first book or my second
book yeah um so that is wonderful anyone
that's listening just search roy
baumeister purpose and meaning
and he kind of distinguishes what
purpose is what meaning is how it
contributes to our lives
second thing is my friend my good friend
who's coming on the show in a couple of
weeks morgan housel do you know who he
is
so he's just written a book which comes
out in two weeks and it's lying on the
floor there because i haven't finished
it sorry morgan
um and it's called the psychology of
money
timeless lessons in wealth greed and
happiness and
it is awesome only 200 pages
real [ __ ] he's a blogger kind of by
trade so it's written in
20 blog blogs kind of um
wonderful and in that he's he had this
quote on on
an episode that he did with me which
just totally nailed it
and he said um wealth is the ferrari
that you didn't buy it's the square
footage in the house that you didn't
purchase
and that very much talks about the
differential between what you and what
you spend what do you need to be happy
and what do you have available
um and it's weird there's not many
things that have an objective measure
you know i can't see objectively how
happy you are i can't see objectively
how fulfilled meaning purpose all that
sort of stuff
but i can't see how much you spend and
how much you earn and those are
two sort of fairly good objective
metrics that kind of
trickle back down right yep i love it i
love it that's really it that sounds
brilliant you'll really really enjoy the
book
um what are friends for what are friends
for what are friends for in the term in
in the
the purpose of the the mirror system
what are they for
um well there's an interesting piece of
research and i use this carefully
because
a magazine approached me and asked me to
write an article
how to think yourself thin and i was
like
that is wrong on so many levels i'm not
going there so suddenly this piece of
research i was slightly more cautious
about sharing but i'll share it now and
it's a
piece of research carried out in 2010
sorry wrong piece of research 2007 12
000 participants over the course of 30
years
looked at how much weight people gained
and looked at how people around them in
terms of
not physically around them in terms of
the proximity of their
friendship if you like so how close they
were
how much weight they gained and if
someone close to you gains weight
you're you're dramatically more likely
to gain weight
and if it's a close friend it's 171
chance that you will put on weight how
does that work
so basically it is how can you have more
than 100 correlation
well it's not a correlation is it's an
increase oh okay yes yes yes yes
yes so um but i just say it's it's
bananas because what it demonstrates is
how we sort of
we just absorb things by osmosis
it's we're absorbing what our friends
are doing
um we absorb moods we absorb stress
there's loads of research that shows you
know
even if a teacher goes into a classroom
stressed the pupils become more stressed
their cortisol levels rise
we're just so interconnected it's just
bananas
no honors so i'm looking here at
the uh research from robert ploman's
blueprint how dna makes us who we are
so yeah this is average ratings of 5 000
uk adults and it's the results of
genetic research
and weight is
weight people thought that the genetic
component to weight was 40
so that was what most people estimated
0.7
you are point seven point seven percent
no it's point seven
of one so it's seventy percent you are
seventy percent
likely to have the bmi or seventy
percent is a correlation your parent's
bmi to yours
and he's done this with twin studies
adoption studies people that are aware
is that a genetic correlation or is it
that he's saying it's environmental
genetic correlation so you can take
twins that are born to the same parents
uh either mono or by uh whatever is
dizygotic or monozygotic either of them
and you can take them and put them in
different households
their correlation to their adoption
parents is
zero zero
really interesting i would love to hear
what you think about
the his book because i'm going to read
it i don't have the
the uh wherewithal to be able to
criticize it but um
i would be really interested to see how
that how that sort of ties into what
we're talking about here i'm not sure i
do either because i'm definitely not
what did you say he was
robert he's a genetic
behavioral geneticist i'm just the
behavioral bit not the genetics but
yeah i get it um so we've got what
friends are for
they they can sort of also mold our
our actions so if that's the case if
it's both good and bad is social
conformity
just part of trying to fit into the
tribe is it just trying to feel part of
the group
yeah and i mean i think this thing this
sort of thing's been discussed quite a
lot over the last few years
i did discuss it in my first book that
wasn't published before everyone was
talking about it but i won't go there
get it back out
and get it get it back out again it's a
bit weird now i think
um anyway i might do i might do um
but yeah the social conformity it's and
and that you'll have no you'll have
heard the research that says we all
think we're not really conformists but
then if if you go
into certain experiments and we all
demonstrate that we do actually all
conform to norms
so we'll do things like adjust our music
taste
in in experiments they've shown how
someone will align their music tastes to
the people they're around without even
realizing they're doing it
people will align their how whether they
think someone's attractive
or not all sorts of things just happen
without us really consciously thinking
about it
um unless you're really stubborn
like me where i deliberately as a
teenager wanted to wear something
different
always to what everyone else was wearing
but that was just all a bit it's hard
work being like that to be honest
isn't it well it's far easier to use the
mirror system
yeah because it does a ton of the
thinking for you absolutely
but that's where so we've got commercial
organizations
leveraging our psychology for one thing
or behavioral science
i think we should be as society as
individuals
leveraging our natural mechanisms which
mirrors thinking is
in effect for good and that's for good
for ourselves and for other people
this sudden implication for something
i've been talking about a lot recently
which is
i get i was on love island i was on the
first uh season
through the door you didn't see i've
written on another island i've
criticized it on
digital spy i didn't know you were on
that sorry i'm being nice
it's absolutely fine i'm gonna go and
check it out now you know go check out
your article and i'm going to tweet you
something nasty if it was about me
no um it wasn't about you my issue with
love island
that everyone's listening knows um is
that it picks up people who very well
might be talented or not but doesn't
choose them for their talents
tommy fury was this great boxer
wonderful amateur boxer just about to
turn pro
but he got famous off the back of being
a guy with a tan on tv
and what it does is it then gives people
who haven't earned it
a platform and the sad thing about
giving people who haven't earned it a
platform
is that now two million people listen to
the person who
won love island 2016 and
think that they by virtue of the size of
this platform
should be able to comment on stuff like
the general election or
get me on this this is just a rabbit
hole for me
so i'm not criticizing you it's not
criticizing your talk i think that i
mean i think one of the
one of the issues with love island is
you i think you take people
vulnerable in one way or another as well
and then you put them in a situation
that makes them even more vulnerable
and then they don't have the support
afterwards that was one of the things i
was only interviewed for this digital
spy article
that's one of the things i was talking
about is i think it makes
it increases the vulnerability and the
pressures and all those things so
there's that piece but then i also think
it creates a hugely unrealistic norm for
the rest of the population because
they're looking at these
people sort of scantily clad young
tanned and they're thinking that's what
i should look like now
that might not be something they
consciously think although often i think
youngsters do
but it's something that then if you talk
about imprinting creates a norm and that
norm
is an unrealistic expectation um
and then the final thing is what you've
just said is the platform
which drives me potty because i mean
it's partly personal because i think
you know i trotted along quite
successfully in my career
doing stuff with really important people
and being taken very seriously and being
listened to
and then suddenly i launched a book and
i'm told to go on social media
and like firstly i don't really like
social media but secondly
i just spent every day feeling like a
failure because
i think why is no one listening to me
because you know
i i studied for seven years to become a
child psychologist
but no one's listening to me
and it's and so that's my personal bug
but in reality you know taking sort of a
step back and looking at it
it does worry me because you have people
who advise on mental health
who whilst they might have experienced
something and it's great to share a
story
whatever your story you can't advise
unless you're trained you shouldn't
you shouldn't be so this is a really
hilarious
paradox that we've stumbled across which
is
the only people on the internet
qualified to give advice
are the people prohibited by law at
giving that advice
so we have a doctor who's one of my best
mates and is always on the show yusef
and he always
prefaces anything he says on the show
with i am not your doctor please speak
to your gp but this is what i think
or just doesn't say anything whereas
some guy who has read a book about the
carnivore diet
or the veganism or watch the game
changes movie can tell you everything
that he thinks about how
enzymes and proteas and all this sort of
stuff works
because precisely because of the fact
that he's unqualified
and doesn't have anything to lose it's a
what as yusuf
says um what board are they going to be
struck off from
like there's no there's no sort of
winning board for that to happen but
i uh i think we both could sort of
tumble down this this love island rabbit
hole for a while but
i certainly have i have faith
um increasingly in social media's
ability to
select for people that are adding value
i think we're seeing this with instagram
removing the light counter
i think that we're seeing this
increasingly with people turning away
from the flashy
uh influencer pro influencer instagram
lifestyle that we've seen maybe for sort
of 2014 to 2019 2020
i think we're starting to see that just
look a bit tarnished it's just a bit
beggy now when you see people they're in
mykonos
everyone's in [ __ ] mykonos all the
time like what why is everyone
they're in bali they're in wherever it
might be and i think it's you seeing
um as an influence as someone who works
with with companies sponsored for the
podcast sponsored for other bits and
pieces as well
they're now looking to pivot more and
more
away from asking me to do stuff on
instagram
and instead asking to sponsor
pre-rolls on the show they would much
sooner be associated with something
which has
a bit more reach but pay a ton more for
it
because they know that the platform has
been uh created through hard work and
virtue and intellectual interest and
curiosity and genuinely connecting with
an audience
as opposed to this bizarre situation
where you can go from nobody to two
million followers
in six weeks when you haven't interacted
with a single member of the people that
follow you
other than uh passively through a camera
um so i think my form is temporary class
is permanent
and i think if you keep continuing to
put out good stuff um
you get what you deserve in the end so
i'm sure that that'll happen for you as
well
i mean aside from that doesn't matter my
aim
i i guess i get frustrated because my
aim is i've worked with all these
privileged people um helping them
understand psychology and what have you
and i thought i want to give it to
everyone else
and then everyone else isn't there to
give it to us
um but uh to your point i mean i do
i i do have i hope hope
rather than i have faith i should say i
have hope that it is going to turn
on its heel a little bit um but i still
you know i i think it's still just like
media would have done it any time
exploits are vulnerable so i've got my
cousins
and i'm hoping that none of them watch
this i don't think they will listen
to it well my cousin's daughter
is a model and she's up to 100
when she was here a couple of years ago
at christmas she was on a few thousand
followers on instagram
and now she's on a hundred and something
thousand
she's absolutely stunning but she shows
her bottom and her tits too much
and actually it really upsets me because
she's an 18 year old and i worry
because i think she's in she's she grew
up in australia and she's now in la and
i think
she's so vulnerable and actually that's
what i'm worried about i'm worried about
the fact that
she's being exploited for her and and
her vulnerability is
and i know that's an age-old thing that
goes back centuries
but it still it still makes it far
easier doesn't it when you've got
social media platforms i had ashley mias
who is a social psychologist on the show
and she
studied the behavior of party girls in
the vip clubbing scene in new york
she did ethnographic research
yeah so she became a party girl for six
months and followed the biggest
brilliant
she used to be a model when she was
younger and now is a sociology
professor ahead of sociology at like new
york
state union like real good and um she
became a party girl
and followed these girls around and
there's an interesting counter to
to the um they're being they're
vulnerable and they're being exploited
because it's quite easy to say that
you've got these girls who basically
don't get paid they just go out for free
with the promoter and they're
filler and they go to the the big tables
with the guys who are spending all the
money and they drink for free
and they get free food before they go
out but it's not the best sushi it's
like the cucumber rolls and stuff like
that
and she said to the girls like look if
you all banded together
you could firstly cut the promoter out
and second they actually get paid for
doing this
rather than just getting stuff for free
and none of the girls wanted to do it
they knew that they were being exploited
but they said well it's just kind of fun
you know it makes us feel special
i don't really want to be paid for it
because it makes it feel like work
i would much just rather kind of come
out and just have it for free and i'm
with the girls
so there'll be a little bit of social
conformity in there but i also
i also think that um
people like being made to feel
wanted by society and by so
i wonder whether you would be able to
even red pill your friend's
daughter or cousin sufficiently my
cousin's daughter yeah
she related to me as well yeah um
i don't know whether you'd be able to
read pillar enough for her to see that i
think that she might
love the adoration that she gets so much
even if she was in
full presence of all the facts
that she'd be like did you know what it
is i prefer the likes i prefer the free
charcoal toothpaste and the whatever
else you've gotten
well then there's the comfort isn't
there of the life that you find yourself
in whereas like you've said she was
saying if you band together well that's
that creates discomfort because you're
then up against conflict straight away
and so
but it is i mean the modern lifestyle is
interesting and
but in the book in the book
i talk about prestige because what's
interesting is
and if we see someone doing something
successfully
from an evolutionary perspective so say
fred went out and caught the antelope
that we've been trying the type of
antelope we've been trying to catch for
ages and we can't catch that antelope
so we go out with fred and we go out a
few times and then
we learn how to catch up antelope
and we come back to the village and
everyone's like wow you caught that
antelope too
i want to be able to catch antelope but
they can't distinguish between
the rain dance that it did before you
went out on the hunt
or the song you sang when you came back
from the hunt
or the way you ran in circles from
what you actually did you take it as a
total you say
okay i need to do all those things in
order to catch that
antelope and that's how our brain sort
works so we'll see
a star advertising cologne and we think
we don't sit and think well in reality
he might wear that clone but that
doesn't mean that if i wore that cologne
i would then be really attractive
all we see is actually globally speaking
if i buy that cologne
i might pull those girls as well and so
it becomes
this sort of scenario which is where
again the two million followers you
think well they've got two million
not you but people think well they've
got two million followers
um therefore i will
do whatever they say and like whatever
they say because
they must know what they're talking
about and they don't
let me tell you from first-hand
experience
those people haven't got a clue it's
interesting as well for me with
the show as a really good example we
said that it's not often you have
objective measures of success
but i do with this this show i have
objective measures of impact
how many subscribers how many play
minutes how many views how many messages
how many blah blah blah blah blah blah
um the show hasn't changed i've been
doing this about three years this hasn't
changed
got a tiny little bit less [ __ ] at
interviewing people
but like for the most part it's just the
same thing i'm talking to the same
people
but it's only now that we've reached
about a million players a month
that people actually care and start
referring to me as a host and
think of me as some sort of authority oh
so much it's
just signaling it's just that there is a
trajectory that people can see the shows
on
they think i'm some sort of authority at
this now when i'm i'm just i'm swimming
in imposter
syndrome and all my latest podcast which
goes out to about 80 people
um what's on imposter syndrome um
i mean i come across imposter syndrome a
lot but what i also come across
is hubris have you heard of hubris can
you explain it to me
yeah so hubris is again as one of these
things it's contentious but
there's a guy called lord david owen
who's a psychiatrist
but he studied basically leaders
in the us and the uk over a hundred year
period to see who had hubris now hubris
is when you tip from being potentially a
good leader
to starting to believe your own rhetoric
um so he uses the example of
tony blair and i don't want to get
political but um
tony blair whether you agreed with his
policies or not you know he was a good
leader he was a good communicator
and he tipped into hubris and i actually
written a policy paper
on the chill cut report and pulled it
apart from cognitive
bias and all that sort of stuff but he
started believing
what he wanted to believe rather than
believing what was going on around him
and they say it's the only acquired
personality syndrome and
it's it's basically you become
narcissistic but i see it so often and
actually i
warn sometimes when i'm seeing people
are just becoming ceo for the first time
i warn them and i say one thing you've
really got to watch out for is
becoming hebristic because as soon as
you become hubristic
you become a bad leader but the problem
is
in celebrity world which i'm
encountering more and more through
stuff i'm doing is no one to say
actually you're a bad leader we're gonna
we're not gonna hire you for the next
role or
we're not gonna elect you people keep
who keeps following them who's going to
be that person that decides to drop an
anchor on the rocket ship that's going
to the moon
that's precisely the same with with the
show with my other buddies that are like
on upward trajectories
um no one gives a [ __ ] about what you
think until you're successful
which is stupid because you think all of
the things that you think now are
exactly the same yeah precisely i have a
friend michael mallis
and he had a book written about him
that's called ego and hubris
oh really yes oh my god i've got such a
long book list from this conversation um
i think that ego and hubris is the
cheapest copy you can get now it's about
150 pounds it's not available digitized
it's crazy have a look at the
things he's been on joe rogan like five
times he's wonderful one of my very very
good friends michael
um let's get back to let's get back to
murray thinking before before we go
i love this quote that you had which was
teachers of the guardians of our mind
when it is most malleable
which has got some really terrifying
implications for choosing your kids
school
and what they're being told by teachers
really worrying
it is really worrying but
um there's also a lot of the research
around role modeling shows that teachers
have a very
very small impact on kids okay so what
does teachers of the guardians of our
mind when it's most malleable me
so when a teacher is bad then
then you see it really having an impact
or when a teacher is exceptionally good
but most of the time teachers through no
fault of their own it's through i think
it's through stress
in the system they're not able to be
exceptional
so what i hear when i'm profiling people
is i hear i
more often hear for the bad teacher than
i do of the good teacher
so that's anecdotal but i'll hear
someone say um
this you know you know it's ridiculous
things like people who are cfos of big
companies have got a
fear around their capability and maths
and you're like what
why it's because a math teacher said
something to them at one point
that has stuck with them through life
that's what worries me because there are
lots of examples of where
kids have been taken off track and i
think the ones i see are the ones who've
made it in spite of that
but if they've carried it with them
anyway but what about all those kids
that then
didn't even follow their dreams because
they believed what that teacher told
them
the more and more that i learned
especially this year this year is like
the year of uncomfortable truths
probably for a lot of people right but
like particularly with the stuff i've
been reading robert ploman stuff about
the
sort of this pre-determination of
genetics and and then mirror thinking as
well it's like
hang on so if you're telling me that i
want to live a consciously designed life
i need to first overcome all of the
[ __ ] that i did in life up until the
point at which i start to
step into my own programming and then
let's say that i managed to
to work my way through that i've then
got just the
like source code that i'm made up of the
bootstrap
program that's kind of built into my
genetics and i've got to try
and yeah in a
society that's meritocratic i think
that's
it's an uncomfortable truth it is it is
and
and you know the the whole reason i
wrote my first book which is about
helping publish the thing fiona no no no
this is that's my
so my my very first book wasn't
published i mean my first published book
which is
so my very first published book um was
to try and democratize what i did with
senior leaders because i
i sort of go through the life and when
i'm going through it i'm piecing
together
what their drivers are what their
passions are what what their tipping
points are
how emotionally resilient they are how
can they be more emotionally resilient
all those sorts of things and then how
can they optimize their behavior to help
other people or to help themselves as
leaders
and so i broke it down into a book
and i said i said to a friend of mine
northern irish she lives in scotland
and i was like air jill so i've done
this and it's to democratize learning so
like
other people that don't have these
opportunities
and she went she works with
underprivileged sort of a really rough
area
and she's like fee all due respect
they're not going to read your book and
i was like oh
[ __ ] sake should have should have done
an infomercial or something on youtube
or tick tock can you do a tick tock oh
no no it's fine i mean i i won two
awards for that book so it did fine it's
fine
double your sales i bet oh i can't i
can't talk um
and then and then um
but the reason i wrote this book was
because i i think there are things that
we can actually take from it
in terms of how we help kids
from less privileged backgrounds so how
can we use the mirror system to
speed up our development there's a lot
of people listening who want to
expedite their success and avoid failure
what are the takeaways that people can
use for self-development
for people in who are sitting watching
this i'm guessing they're not sort of
stuck in a council flat somewhere so
there might be might be might be and
they're
whoever it is listening it's about
being aware so deciding
what what do you want where do you want
to go then being
conscious of who is going to help you go
in that direction
and then making sure and this sounds a
bit weird but you're exposed to those
people
so um you know if you want to if
so say you are stuck in in in a really
rubbish area really run down there's no
one successful around you
you want to be successful read
biographies
watch biographies on tv think about what
people
are doing watch them observe them see
how they're doing things that mean that
they
have got to where you want to get to not
the global prestige thing but the
individual behaviors
so martin nelson mandela when he was in
prison
for those 27 years he read biographies
non-stop he
wrote letters to other leaders he he
sort of examined
history it this all the information is
there but it takes
effort to find it if we're not
surrounded by it
if we're in a more lucky position and we
are surrounded by it
make sure that if you want to be fitter
surround yourself by fit friends
if you want to be a better communicator
listen to people who communicate well
but don't just listen
think about how they communicate well
and so it's bringing
everything into awareness which is hard
work you don't want to do it all the
time
so if you want a lazy way you just
surround yourself with people
who you'd quite like to be like
is the you are the sum of the five
people you spend the most time with
is that true it's partially true isn't
it but it's
why you're attracted to people in the
first place because they like you and
then it reinforces
how you are such a complication bias
that thing isn't it yeah but then
there's people like you
who are really curious and you want to
get underneath things and
and so you're more likely to be
surrounded by people who aren't
necessarily like you
um and that's no bad thing either
because that stretches us beyond
our our comfort zone and i i'm
really really proud i think the power of
curiosity is immense
you're among friends here fiona it's
i've said it
on every podcast i've been on that's not
been this one for like the last couple
of years curiosity
is the number one personality trait for
the 21st century
because it it sits outside of the
confirmation bias
it's a desire to ask why to look into
things
which inevitably leads you down
sometimes like catastrophe
but more often than not just like
interesting
adventures intellectually physically
spiritually
whatever it might be absolutely and and
if you meet someone who's not like you
if you sit there and you think they're
not like me and obviously we don't sit
in pubs and things anymore but when we
used to
you turn away or if you sit and you talk
to them firstly you will find something
that is like you
in some way or another but secondly you
can learn so much more about the world
if someone's not like you
so how do they see the world what do
they find exciting and interesting
what can you learn from them and then
you can mirror that stuff if you want to
and you can also make use what was it
counter mirroring
yeah yes so you can also make use of a
bad role model bizarrely
absolutely and actually weirdly it tends
to have a bigger impact because people
are more conscious of counter mirroring
of saying i don't want to be like that
that's so with doctors there's been a
lot of research you don't mention your
friend who's a doctor
there's been a lot of research in role
modeling for doctors it's the only way
that they think you can pass on empathic
skills as a doctor
which is interesting there's also the
fact that
junior doctors that are wither an
unethical
senior will either
un unwittingly take on some of that
themselves and take that through their
career
or they will be so adverse to it that it
they go completely the other way
and they're like i am completely ethical
i'm following the ethics i am doing
everything by the book
the implications of our actions are so
wide-ranging
it's really terrifying like the the fact
that we're not in open rebellion
against each other or getting hit by
traffic or
you know like it it blows my mind
because
the number of different ways that your
actions
can affect other people positively
negatively
it's just as well that we don't
either have the capacity to or choose to
uh observe our thoughts and actions with
the level of dexterity that we we
perhaps could
we would get nothing done we'd just
constantly be in inertia um
but yeah it is um it's mad the
butterfly effect of the things that we
do is really crazy isn't it it is
it's immense fiona this has been really
cool mirror thinking
how role models make us human will be
linked in the show notes below on
amazon anywhere else that you want
people to go any other stuff they should
check out
oh yeah why not follow me on twitter and
instagram so i actually have some
followers that would be great
great and um what's your instagram
fiona martin fiona martin without a dot
no dart yes no doubt um fiona madden
fiona martin fionaman on linkedin
um facebook whatever but
also i've got a podcast and i've been
not not these amazing authors that
you've been talking about but i've
spoken to some brilliant people like
um the ceo of doc martens who's a friend
and editor-in-chief of mary claire and
she talked about you know when she was
she was doing that ethnographic research
as a return list with
harvey weinstein and pretending to be a
an actress
yeah that's a really interesting one you
probably like that one
what's your podcast called dot dot
behind the person
dr dot so joining the dots on behavior
and so it's basically exploring people
from what i do behind closed doors but
trying to give other people some
some insight into that as well but if
that sounds interesting go and check out
fiona's podcast will be linked in the
show notes below
uh let me know what you think i think
this there's a lot of implications
i know we've been through quite a lot of
different rabbit holes today but um
comments below or drop me a message at
chriswellx wherever you follow me
but for now fiona thank you so much
thank you so much thanks a lot
you